hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to let
me look at the title the video
how to approach woman in the gym in
field approach
i've been watching a lot of videos that
i think are like geared towards men
lately and honestly like
i'm just curious if any of these pickup
games like would work or like if i think
they're good
so let's let's find out
shall we okay make this large
guys make sure to click the link below
and get my free ebook unplugging from
the matrix of fitness and game
totally free get on my newsletter going
to provide a lot of content that isn't
safe for youtube or instagram
and i'll catch you guys there let's get
into this that's safe
i'd like you guys to know i do lift
sometimes
so you could say that i'm an expert so
if you guys haven't already you should
go watch my video on how to meet women
at the gym carter will be up top
and in that video one of the tips i gave
was you don't want to talk to women that
work out at your home gym
you want to go to other gyms that might
be a part of your chain
or gym that you're not necessarily a
member at and meet women
there and the reason why is because you
don't want to upset
the environment at which you train and
make things awkward for yourself and
the girl okay true
true that's good advice so you want to
talk to women at other gyms where
there's not going to be that much of a
social consequence
if you were to fail or strike out with
that and like
okay let's say he approached one girl
right and she said no
maybe like the second girl he would have
approached would have said yes but like
if i saw someone like try to hit on
another girl and then try to talk to me
like i'd be like okay you're just
hitting on everybody now that said
when you are at the gym how do you go
about this well if you see a pretty girl
timing is very important obviously when
you're at a bar or during the day
you have to act immediately right she's
she's there
she's walking you got to make a decision
am i going to approach this girl or am i
going to forever
never be able to meet my possible wife
just kidding but the point is is that
you need to make a decision immediately
with the gym you need to be
calculated in how you move hear the
don'ts do not talk to her when she's in
the middle of a set
or on a cardiovascular machine where
she's panting on a stair climber or
whatever it may be
in between sets or when she's on her way
out the gym
or even if right before when she walks
in and what you're going to do is
you're going to approach her again same
with during meeting at night
or during the day strong masculine
introduction
and you're going to say something along
the lines of hey i'm new to this gym i
don't come off and
i just want to meet you real quick let
her talk to you a little bit and assess
her body language now the thing is with
this is you want to see
how she responds to the interaction if
she's obviously very focused has her
headphones in and she's
she doesn't want to talk to you she's
going to be very apparent her answers
are going to be short
and abrupt and she's probably going
gonna try to get around you which is
fine
take the hint uh and don't don't try to
engage anymore don't watch
good advice because if someone tries to
like hit on you
and they don't leave it alone it makes
them seem very clingy and very desperate
so if you just like walk away like and
like you know you're worth the girls
might just be like
like damn i kind of liked that attention
i don't know how to describe it
and you never know like she might not
change your mind at all but
like that's a better strategy than the
pastor says guys watch what she does
her body language is going to tell you
the truth so if she walks away from you
doesn't really engage or invest in a
conversation ask you questions about
yourself
she's probably not interested move on
but with that
said when you do find a girl that is
interacting positively with you whether
she's looking up at you asking questions
about yourself
um asking where you're from these are
all good signs that she's investing in a
conversation and might want to get to
know you
now with the gym you want to keep the
conversation fairly short okay short and
sweet the way you do this is hey you
seem really cool obviously we both got a
train
i'd like to go out with you some time
let's grab a drink or a coffee or a
protein shake whatever
line you want to use you set the stage
to meter at a later time
at a later date and as always you
control the interaction where
you're setting up the date right there
and then and you're finding a time place
and location okay i will say if
a guy asked me to get a drink i would be
personally
less likely to go out with him because
especially
if he had the confidence to approach me
like as a girl like i'm always thinking
like i hope this isn't like
someone that's just like super thirsty
or whatever and so if a guy asked me to
get a drink
like i personally would be more likely
to say yes to coffee is what
i would advise but it also depends what
you're looking for
that is favorable to you and that will
put you in a good light where you'll be
able to demonstrate leadership qualities
that make you attractive as a guy but
the biggest thing with the gym guys
is you need to be able to read social
cues and read body language very well
that's why this is a little bit more
advanced if you're not
familiar with cold approaching you
definitely want to get your reps in
doing night game and day game so that
you can properly assess
indicators of interest and respond
accordingly versus in the gym
it's a little bit harder the
interactions got to be condensed and you
have to be able to quickly pick up
on good signs versus bad signs and make
real-time decisions
quickly and decisively so if the girl's
not interested you got to be able to cut
that interaction right away
and do it in a socially acceptable
manner don't sit there and be like
well screw you anywhere i don't want to
talk to you or be butt-hurt or angry or
try to be little
if she's not interested say hey take it
as a compliment
have a good workout yeah like that's a
hundred percent true like the least
attractive like okay
i remember i was dating a guy a couple
years ago and i told him that like i
didn't
like want to date him anymore and like
what he did was he just said okay like
if that's what you want to do
and that was so much more attractive
than like if he begged me or asked me
why
or whatever like he knew his value he
knew he'd find a different girl whatever
and like so i'm just i'm just trying to
say like
guys like know your value just because
one girl doesn't see it doesn't mean
someone else won't and walk away because
when you show emotion
that's low value behavior shows that
you're not strong as a guy to take
rejection
yeah and it just it's just low value you
never want to come off as an emotional
guy that's unstable that
is outcome dependent you want to be
outcome independent you want to let her
a reaction
to your approach dictate how you feel
you make the approach
basically what you're doing is you're
doing a cold sales call
if she's not interested move on to the
next or continue on with your workout
the priority should be to go to the gym
and train guys it shouldn't be just to
pick up women
but a byproduct of you being there if
you see a cute girl that you want to
talk to
you can do it in a gym that you don't
belong to in
socially acceptable manner that doesn't
put yourself in a bad position or the
girl
so that she'll be more open to meeting
you and actually why is this girl
in the youtube video is she's just there
for clickbait or is he gonna
one of the things you can do when you
interact with her is tell her hey i
don't come to this gym i just wanted to
try it out and what that does it disarms
her to want to invest in an interaction
because if she knows that you're not a
regular member at the gym
she's going to be more apt to talk to
want to meet with you but if she knows
you're going to be a regular there
she's not going to want to deal with you
because she understands that if the
interaction doesn't go well that will
have
long-term consequences socially later on
when she wants to go to the gym and
train
true true that's very true so it might
be
smart to tell her from the beginning of
the interaction hey it's my first time
here i'm just trying it out
uh but i actually belong to this other
gym then that will kind of disarm her
in the gym you've got to have had i've
the only times i've actually like
entertained a guy who
like that actually worked that actually
made conversation with me at the gym
is he was help he asked me to help him
with the set
for weights okay and was that just like
balancing and i was like okay
so i'm not going to like say no because
i don't want to be in i was like okay
fine let me help you really quick
okay but no i i really don't look
approachable at the gym i have my
headphones in
and i just like don't but but has anyone
ever tried i know someone's tried
they definitely i really don't pay
attention to people and i really look i
literally
am like don't talk to me cap
every girl that said that says this is
lying
i i doubt it literally look
unapproachable at the gym okay so if you
actually have like
you know confidence enough to come to me
i'm like wow because like
i really like don't you know what i mean
like i don't like i'm not like oh wow
like you know i just go in there and get
out but
uh yeah i don't know but if the right
guy approaches you
if a guy shows no interest and i've seen
him work out
like you know you kind of know regulars
but you don't know him like but you see
him work out
like oh yeah i know this guy because he
shows up at the same time i show up
and then he finally makes conversation
i'm more willing to talk to that guy
that i see all the time who's never
bugged me before but i you know we work
out at the same time after work
versus as like someone who's like
staring at me
and then tries to talk to me i'd be like
okay leave me alone so there you go guys
you got some insider information right
there
don't forget to like comment subscribe
share this
okay let me
so i think that was all good advice i
would agree
like i i think that i never thought of
that like from a guy's perspective
but the idea of like going to a gym you
don't normally go to that's
that's smart that's really smart um on
top of that i don't really have money
comments don't forget to like comment
and subscribe especially subscribe
trying to move up move out of my parents
house every single day
i will talk to you guys next time